by Adam Marcus from Princeton and he'll
tell us about existence proofs of
Ramanujan dress thank you very much
it's may be unfortunate that this was
this talk wasn't before wills because
it's going to fill in maybe some of the
gaps that he wasn't able to cover but
I'll try very hard to point out places
in my talk where the things that he said
are relevant so this is to existence
proofs of ROM news and graphs and it's
joint work with Dan Spielman and who's
at Yale and Nikhil who is here at the
University at UC Berkeley all right so I
want to start with our motivation which
is sort of a problem in combinatorial
linear algebra so we call it and the
question is this so if I have a 1
through a n which are independent random
positive semi-definite matrices I want
to find upper bounds on the lambda max
of the sum over I this should be sorry
no hat here this sum over the AI where
the AI are in the support of the AI of
the AIS are the hats so I have these
random matrices that I'm concerned about
what I want to do is cheat and I want to
find the assignments which give me the
smallest maximum eigen value that I can
possibly get and I want to figure that
out and I want to get balance on that
thing and one way we could try to do it
is using the probabilistic method right
if we can show that the probability that
this lambda max of this thing is less
than T is greater than zero then what we
would be able to show is that theta is
less than T right there would be
something that satisfies that and there
are numerous techniques for bounding
these types of quantities this
probability of land up max of of these
some of those matrices and there's a
whole sort of series of these they're
called matrix Chernov Bernstein huffing
azuma which say that if a1 through a n
are in our D by D or independent random
semi-definite matrices then you get a
bound exactly what you need the
probability that lambda max is greater
than T is less than or equal to B times
some e to some function that grows very
fast so this thing gets very small but
at the same time there's this D here so
there are similar inequalities by Ruud
Olson else way to winter and trop and
all of them have two things in common
their concentration bounds and the
bounds depending on the dimension right
this D here and it sort of has to be
that way so this is the bad seed so if
you picked v1 through VD to be
independent random matrices which just
took each of these matrices uniformly at
random so with probability one over D
then it should be clear that theta V one
through V D equals one right because it
for each V I I pick a different one of
these matrices it adds up to the
identity so that's the highest you can
get but as a problem probability problem
this becomes a balls and bins problem
right you're throwing diagonal entries
and you're asking when are they all in
sort of separate bins so assume you have
n identical balls for each ball you pick
one of n different bins then if Zi is
the number of balls in bin I then the
well-known fact is that the expected
maximum of zi is log n over log log n so
something that grows to infinity
certainly not one even worse for us the
probability that you are close to this
thing is very close to one so there's
not really anything that's gonna be able
to drag us down and if we were trying to
get something that was asymptotically
tight for this problem we're in much
bigger problems because the probability
that you actually get one is something
that's exponentially small okay so what
this example shows you is that if I
wanted to get better bounds let's say
asymptotically tight bound
that don't depend on the dimension then
I'm gonna need to start capturing then
find a way to capture low probability
events and this was previously not
possible in a spectral setting you know
the sort of thing that the Lobos local
EMA does and the key idea for us was to
switch from matrices to polynomials so
the characteristic polynomial of a
matrix is the determinant of x times the
identity minus that matrix and the key
fact is that the roots of these of the
characteristic polynomials are the
eigenvalues of a so for any self-adjoint
matrix we can replace this lambda max of
a with maximum roots of the
characteristic polynomial of a and for a
random matrix we can say the probability
that lambda max of a is less than or
equal to T is the probability that's the
max root of pi a of X is less than or
equal to P because just looking at
exactly what we have and this suggests
studying random characteristic
polynomials my first plane is that this
is kind of a silly suggestion but I have
a section on it so it can't be that
silly but let's see what what actually
I'm saying so if a is a matrix and V is
a random vector taking values u or W
uniformly then what would we be
considering we'd be considering one-half
times the characteristic polynomial
where we've added uu transpose plus 1/2
times the characteristic polynomial
where we've added W w transpose and
there's this issue that when we add
polynomials it's a function of the
coefficients right and we're interested
in the roots and going from roots to
coefficients is easy you just multiply
out the polynomial X minus the roots but
going from coefficients to roots is hard
right this is what Galois theory tells
us and in particular you may not even
have a sum that makes any sense with
respect to your original thing so here
is here are two polynomials P and Q one
has a double root at one one has a
double root of minus one and when you
add them together you get roots that are
imaginary numbers and so
it's hard to be able to compare 1 and -1
with square root of minus 3 for example
but it turns out that a special
condition sort of allows us to be able
to do that and we call it root
separation so if the P I P I is a
collection of degree D polynomials and s
T is an interval such that all of the P
I of s are greater than equal to 0 and
all of the P I are less than or equal to
0 at T and H P I has exactly one real
root in s T then the sum over I of P I
has at least one real root in st that
lies between the roots of some PA and PB
and the proof is very easy and I'll show
it by picture so if every one is
positive at s then that means their sum
is positive at s if every one is non
positive at t then the sum is not
positive so at some point the sum
crossed 0 so it has to have a root there
and if you look at the point where the
route crosses 0 this is going to be a
sum of values of polynomials which add
up to 0 so one of them will be greater
than or equal to 0 and one of them will
be less than or equal to 0 and that one
will have a root which is on either side
of of this root so and the point is that
if you happen to have DS such intervals
what does that mean that means you have
d intervals with at least one real root
in it well when you add these two degree
D polynomials together it's a degree D
polynomial so it only has D real roots
so it must be that it has exactly D real
roots and there's exactly one root in
each of those places and if you sort of
iterate this this argument you get a
bound which at least in the rank one
case which was mentioned by will in the
previous talk so if a 1 through a n are
random independent to rank 1 positive
semi definite matrices then if I let P
of X be the expected characteristic
polynomial so for each matrix like
former characteristic polynomial and
average those characteristic polynomial
that happens to have only real roots and
there exists an AI in an AI Prime in the
support of these AIS such that the K
through 12 ei I is is less than the case
root of this expected one and these K
through 28 or than wrinkled to this one
so this expected characteristic
polynomial is somehow a bellwether for
both directions excuse me comes from
distribution see how they all have the
same no they all have different
distributions and they're not really
okay so and they they're not really you
know classical random matrices
necessarily you could pick like you know
I have matrix a which I really like and
matrix B which I kind of like and I
choose between the two of them right
it's not necessarily like random as in
the the entries are random or something
like that it's just essentially function
I mean there should be a condition on
the distribution right now there's no
condition I mean apart from being
independent yeah I mean if if each one
was only one then this would be a silly
statement right let there be equality is
everywhere I mean the collection of a is
that a I had is allowed to be right so
if I pick between a and B I want to be
able to plug in either A or B and be
able to get something and the claim is
that there's a an assignment of the
first a is that happen with maybe not
nonzero probability if you have this if
you have a you know a continuous
distribution but in a discrete setting a
nonzero probability of having those AI
is in a non zero probability of having
these AI prime such that this they sort
of surround the root of the
for every K there exists such an AI
collection of a eyes and AI crimes yes
yes that will actually come in later
important I mean I should mention that
Michael Cohen FRA who's a grad student
MIT has a way to extend this to larger
rank matrices but only if you're
interested in the largest route so his
theorem says that if a1 through a n are
random independent positive
semi-definite matrices of any type then
the bound that you're supposed to look
for is the one that you would get if
these be eyes had been rank one matrices
random rank one matrices in such a way
that the expectations match up so he
calls this rank one of vacation and both
of these proof use what we call the
method eventually some polynomials but
that's not really what I want to talk
about today
so I want to switch gears to talk about
expand the graphs and we'll mentioned
earlier that sort of the ultimate
expander graph is the D regular infinite
tree-like and so in some ways when we're
talking about what makes a good expander
we should be asking what makes a good
approximation of this tree as a finite
graph and of course the spectral theory
our definition of good is going to be in
terms of eigen values and it turns out
that the spectrum of the D regular
infinite realize inside this interval
minus 2 square roots of D minus 1/2
squares of B minus 1 so the question is
can we get a finite graph to have all of
its values inside this interval and of
course the answer is no particularly
because the adjacency matrix of a D
regular graph has at least one what are
called trivial eigen values which
corresponds to the all ones vector which
has the eigen value of D and if your
graph happens to be bipartite then minus
D is also an eigenvalue and so we call
those eigenvalues trivial and then we
can ask whether all the rest of them are
in this minus 2 square roots of D minus
1/2 squares of D minus 1 and if they are
then we call it a Ramanuja graph and if
we have a collection of these things
that are all d regular we call it a Rama
Newton family and the famous theorem of
alone and bopanna said that you can't do
any better than this so if you have any
smaller interval you cannot possibly
contain all of the non-trivial eigen
values of an infinite collection of d
regular graphs this is the best you can
hope for question is can you do it and
the answer was confirmed in the positive
by Margulis and separately liubot see
Phillip since our nack who proved that
Ramanuja families exist when the degree
of the graph is P plus 1 for P a prime
number and this was extended by
Morgenstern to D equals P to the K plus
1 but was unknown for all other D and
their constructions were algebraic right
they were Cayley graphs of some very
highly structured groups that there
able to reason about then again on the
other hand almost everything is almost
ramen ocean so a theorem of Friedman
says that if you're willing to be off by
some epsilon then as n gets large you
will be within that epsilon with
extremely high probability so the
obvious question is Aram Newton family
is really a special artifact of these
algebraic structures or do they exist in
some other generality and I'd like to
give two proofs of their existence
so the first proof which is what is the
is what wills proof was an extension of
I'm gonna call the topological proof and
the idea is like he said using covering
spaces so it's easy to find small graphs
that a Raman Newton so for instance KD
the complete graph on D vertices has all
non-trivial eigenvalues minus 1 and k DD
has all non-trivial eigenvalues 0 so
that's easy to be Rama Newton and be Lu
and lineal suggested treating the
average D regular graph as a quotient of
the infinite degree D tree with respect
to a covering that what was their idea
you start with KD or KD d and you
construct a sequence of graphs it
interpolates between kg and your
original graph and your infinite tree d
regular tree using a series of what they
call lifts and what does that mean in a
graph setting so in a graph setting you
would start with a presumably Ramanuja
and graph and then you would make a copy
of it possibly many copies and then you
would do some perturbation to these
edges and the goal would be to then try
to find some perturbation that makes
this new graph romney Lucien supposedly
since you started with the ramanuja
graph that should maybe is not as hard
as just you know picking edges randomly
so be Lewin lineal suggested
perturbations they call two lifts and a
to lift comes in one of two versions
either there's a positive edge lift or a
negative edge lift and the action of
each to lift can be described by a
signed adjacency matrix so which is
exactly what you would think it is it's
the normal adjacency matrix except
rather than all ones you put a one if
there's a positive edge and a minus one
if there's a negative edge and this is
the matrix that you would in Wills
construction you would replace rather
with ones with ones and minus ones ones
with blocks of permutations and then the
perspective of the conjugate permutation
or inverse permutation and what be luan
lineal showed was that if G is a d
regular Ramanuja graph with n vertices
and you have the S which is a signing of
the edges so you put plus or minus one
on each of these things to determine
whether you do a positive or a negative
ship swap if all of the eigenvalues of a
s lie in this interval minus 2 squared
15 minus 1/2 square root of d minus 1
then the two lifts is also a d regular
omniVision graph but now it has 2n
vertices right so this is essentially
what will said that the eigenvalues of
this new graph are going to be a union
of the eigenvalues of the old graph with
the eigenvalues of some modified
adjacency matrix in our cases assigned
adjacency matrix in his case it was his
block adjacency matrix
and if you start with something that had
good ramanuja
maybe that had good wagon values to
begin with and this new thing has good
eigenvalues then the whole thing has
connected values and they conjectured
that every D regular graph contains such
a signing and we can prove this
conjecture for every bipartite graph g
and i want to mention something about
being bipartite why does why is this
necessary in this case the signed
adjacency matrix you can write it in
block form so you have 0 and then B and
then B transpose in 0 and this causes
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors to come
in pairs so in particular if you know
that lambda i is an eigenvalue then
minus lambda i is an eigenvalue and so
the corollary is that a bipartite signed
adjacency matrix has all of its
eigenvalues in this interval if and only
if its eigenvalues are at most two
squares of b minus 1 and this gets back
to what you were asking about the
quantifier we can only say something
about one roof at a time and so in order
to bounce something and this interval we
sort of have to cheat in a way that
allows us to reduce it to saying
something about one eigenvalue and the
main idea is to consider the
characteristic polynomial of a signed
adjacency matrix and this corresponds to
either picking Delta I plus Delta J or
Delta I minus Delta J right deal you'll
get something on the you'll get D on the
diagonal regardless of what you pick and
then if you pick Delta I plus Delta J
you'll get a plus on the off diagonal
and you'll get a minus on the off
diagonal if it's Delta minus Delta J if
you do that independently then you've
satisfied the conditions of our theorem
and so the corollary is that there
exists assigning a star such that the
maximum root of P s star is less than or
equal to the maximum roots of the
expected polynomial over all signings so
now with suffice this to bound this
expected characteristic polynomial and
fortunately for us this has already been
done first of all what is the expected
characteristic polynomial has already
been done
it turns out that if you take the
expectation over all of the possible
signings you get the matching polynomial
of G this was something that we'll also
mentioned in his it extensions and
separately in a paper of hilemon and
lead which is actually where the
matching polynomial was injured
originally introduced in statistical
physics they showed that if G is a graph
with maximum degree Delta then the
maximum root of MU G this matching
polynomial is less than or equal to two
squares of Delta minus one
there's exactly what we're looking for
so piecing things together there exists
bipartite Raman bution families of the
greedy for any D you start with k DD or
KD you take a lift our theorem implies
that there exist some lifts whose
maximum root is that most 2 square roots
of D minus 1 this combines the matching
polynomial and the bound on the matching
polynomial and then you iterate it is
exactly what we'll was talking about and
this technique extends to K lifts by
Hall pooter and 7 so now I want to talk
about is quite different proof that
seemed like a very similar proof but now
we believe it's sort of quite different
we side to which I call in algebraic
proof and the proof idea sort of comes
like this so if I wanted to understand
the infinite tree one way to do that is
to realize that it's the Cayley graph of
the 3 group right
and in algebra they have this
construction that they call a free
product which allows you to take free
groups and build bigger free groups all
right so I can take a free group of size
you know ten and then I can turn it into
a free group of size eleven by adding
another another copy and if you've done
any sort of computational things with d
regular random graphs you realize that
that's sort of how we also build these d
regular random graphs at least multi
graphs is you take a matching and you
put it down and then you add another
matching and then you add another random
matching you got another random matching
so they both have this sort of building
from pieces sort of idea and so the
question is can we figure out whether a
graph is Ramanuja nor can we build a
robert ocean graph using this sort of
construction just put down a matching
then put down another matching
maintaining Ramanuja in this then put
down another matching which maintains
Ramanuja nist but now for a different D
it'll be B plus one but continuing in
that manner and what's happening here
well the adjacency matrix of a perfect
matching on two and Versys has
eigenvalues one and minus one
each end times and when you Union these
graphs multigraphs what you're doing is
you're summing the adjacency matrices so
the question is can I find some
permutation of you know this original
matrix B such that the eigenvalues of a
plus b are small now the issue is that
the eigenvalues of a and B a plus B
depend on the eigenvalues of a the
eigenvalues of B and then the dot
product of the corresponding
eigenvectors right so the heuristic here
since you have ones and minus ones you
kind of hope they'll sort of balance
each other out if you sort of distribute
everything evenly so what you want to
try to do is to keep eigenvalues low you
want sort of all of these dot products
to be as close to uniform as possible of
course you don't have very many choices
for B because your
you know this is a graph polynomial and
well and a is a graph polynomial is a
graph matrix Jason C majors as well
so what if we try to add a and B
randomly this is a thought experiment so
let's look at a plus R B R transpose
where R is a hard distributed random
orthogonal matrix so I'm looking at all
possible rotations well it turns out as
d goes to infinity the probability of
having a large dot product with a fixed
vector goes to 0 you're sort of almost
guaranteed to be far away from any fixed
vector this is a property of volumes and
large dimensions and if you look at this
in some sort of limits this idea of
close to uniform happens with
probability 1 and the resulting
eigenvalue distribution can be
calculated and this has been done and
it's known as the free convolution and
it turns out that so the study of these
types of operations is known as free
probability and it is a a very common
exercise to compute the convolution of d
copies of a Bernoulli random variable
which if you remember this is exactly
what our adjacency matrix is and the
free convolution of d copies of a
Bernoulli random variable is known as
the kesan michaela and it's given here
but for our purposes the interesting
part is that it's support is on the
interval plus minus 2 squares of d minus
1 fact where we were before so now you
might ask can we do something similar in
finite dimensions right we're not really
able to push D to infinity first of all
and the answer is yes so we call this
sort of a quadrature results so if a and
B are n by n matrices where you know the
where P of X is determinant of X I minus
a in determined X minus B then we say
the finite free convolution of P and Q
is
this integral overall determinants of X
I minus a minus RB r transpose overall
rotations R and the finite free
convolution of real root of polynomials
always has real roots it turns out I'm
sorry the choice of Ian it depends on
the eigen values of a and B eigen values
of B yeah only so this is a function of
P of X and Q of X a harder question can
we do something someone with adjacency
matrices right we're not allowed to sort
of integrate over all possible Jade
rotations sorry this is what we call the
quadrature result this is a quadrature
Phillip fluoxetine matrices what we can
show is that if a and B are matrices
such that the all ones vector is an
eigen value of both a and B then what
you can do is you can strip off this
eigen value and you can do the same sort
of calculation in the previous thing
where you form a convolution and what
you get is exactly what you would get if
you took the expectation over all
permutations of B of this characteristic
polynomial of their sum where P is a
uniformly distributed permutation matrix
and now since this is an expected
characteristic polynomial we can say
something using this corollary of
interlacing families that one of these
random one of these matrices has to do
better than what the average does so the
theory of quadrature Phillip lasty
matrices extended says that not only
does this finite convolution exist that
but also there exists a p0 such that the
largest roots of the I'm sorry there
should be no expectation here the
characteristic polynomial where you plug
in P 0
it's smaller than the largest root of
this expected 1 p0 now as a permutation
because we can we can do this as a sum
over permutations right what we showed
is that you can that summing over
permutations at least in the case which
is orthogonal to the all ones vector is
it gives you the same answer as what you
would get if you did the rotation so you
can do the computation using all the
rotations but then you can get a
guarantee that one of the permutation
matrices does it yes it's certainly
conceivable yeah
can you state the conjecture so I'll
mention something at the end maybe and
our original proof uses random swaps to
build an interlacing family I think
probably we don't even need that now
with Michael Cohen's result that allows
us to use general matrices so lastly we
need to compare where we created this
finite version of a free convolution we
need to compare the free and finite free
convolutions and what we're able to show
is that the support of the finite free
convolution of two distributions always
lies inside the support of the free
convolution of those distributions so
the largest root is always smaller than
the edge of the spectrum of the free
convolution and the smallest root is
always larger than the edge of the
spectrum of the left edge of the
spectrum of the free convolution finite
free is an average the finite free is
this computation phrase over here with
just define I'd matrices but it's
regular over all of your final group of
the Italian orthogonal group it turns
out not to matter so you can do
orthogonal group you can do this unitary
group you can do the
so because these are the these are
essentially the first-order Jack
polynomials so like they they're all the
same on and like they're independent of
beta and then you can do that so then
when D goes to infinity that becomes the
free the real free convolution and what
we can show is that the finite version
is inside the spectrum of the free one
of the infinite one so putting
everything together this gives that for
all D and all even n there exists a D
regular bipartite Ramanuja and multi
graph on n vertices so very similar to
what we'll is able to show and I should
disclose that because of the bikepark
tightness the actual proof of this is a
little more complicated like we need to
use a different convolution which
preserves by part tightness
but the proof idea is sort of similar it
just uses a uses singular values rather
than eigen values okay so the first
question i want to talk about is this
idea of a polynomial time constructions
certainly has already come up and a
theorem of michael cohen again the grad
student MIT says that the Ramanuja in
multi graphs which were provided by the
second proof are constructible in
polynomial time and the way he does this
is he sort of takes these polynomials
and extends them to what are called real
stable polynomials by adding extra
variables and then he uses those
variables to sort of keep information
which sort of gives him hints about what
the original which of the two whether
the plus or the minus was chosen for
that for each thing and i should remark
that matching polynomials in particular
are probably not constructible in
polynomial time just in particular the
0th coefficient is the or the constant
coefficient is the number of perfect
matchings so certainly the first way any
sort of naive way of trying to implement
what we're doing here is probably not
going to work because you would have to
in particular construct the matching
polynomial it's certainly possible that
there's some sort of like random walk
way of doing
that you know did find some minimum and
doesn't actually know what the minimum
is and then this could show that this is
the minimum but at least the naive way
of doing it certainly wouldn't exist on
the other hand there's the similarity is
that they both use this method of
interlacing polynomials and in
particular the two things I want to
point out are that in the first first
case well in both cases the expected
characteristic polynomial was computable
there's absolutely no reason to believe
that when I integrate over a bunch of
like random polynomials that I should be
able to figure out what that polynomial
is and secondly the bounds were
asymptotically tight right it's you know
as we saw with Freedman it's very well I
don't want to say easy but it's it's
certainly not construct a gorilla mcli
hard to find something that's very close
to Ramanuja n-- but there is but it
turns out to be a little bit more
complicated to get on the other side of
rama Newton and if you remember what the
bound I gave you at the very beginning
with these polynomials I mean when I
gave you this bound it's sort of is like
me telling you that I'm taller than my
cousin right that means so on one hand
if you don't know who my cousin is that
means nothing to you and secondly if you
know that my cousin is 2 years old
that also means nothing to you right I
mean so you have to be able to construct
this and it has to actually be good so
it's sort of nice and and a similar one
similarity is that both of these exist
happen in this case the difference is
one is that the output of the original
one is is guaranteed to be a graph in
the second one we have no way of ruling
out the possibility that you could get a
multi graph which is a ramanuja multi
graph and of course the first one we
believe has no construction in the
second release any naive construction in
the second one does contain a
construction and the recent work tries
to explain why these
but the differences are between these
two methods and it comes down to a
theory that do we call finite free
probability which is essentially
understanding these operations of finite
free convolution in the same way that
free probabilists understand their free
convolutions so future work here are
some questions that I'm particularly
interested in so the first question is
to complete the analogy so the we've
seen that you can sort of do this finite
free probability by doing a combination
of univariate polynomials we have very
similar things so it's actually been
very nice that that are that many of our
results are related to the results in
free probability because every time that
we have a question we can sort of look
and see what this similar answer is and
free probability and that gives us sort
of an inspiration as to what to look for
in the multivariate case we have no idea
what this correspondence is whether it
exists or whether it's you know some
extension of free probability that we
don't know but I
somebody had any ideas on that I would
love to know and in particular you can
think of this comparison of finite free
convolution with free convolution as a
statement about operations that combine
polynomials into a new polynomial what
the bound on the roots of this new
polynomial are based on the roots of the
original two polynomials one interesting
question would be whether there's a
similar inequality in the multivariate
session in the multivariate version that
in particular would imply this hilum and
leave bound so if you look at the
original proof of the Heilmann leave
bound it's very very intimately uses the
fact that it is a matching polynomial
and not just a polynomial that's going
under that's being you know just having
something done to it and if you move to
the multivariate case you can sort of
turn at least the proof that this thing
is real rooted into sort of a property
of polynomial
rather than a property of matching
polynomials and so so then another
question is root inequalities one thing
we've noticed is that in a lot of
situations there seems to be this major
ization order that goes along with
various operations and if you could find
something like this this would imply
exactly what you're asking that the the
largest and the smallest root are both
smaller and in particular doing such a
thing would get rid of the word
bipartite I want to sort of advertise
other applications of this finite free
probability idea so apart from the
additive convolution we have a
multiplicative convolution we have
additive and multiplicative Brownian
motions we have some idea of what
entropy should be Fisher information and
recently a combinatorial theory has been
built around it so sort of a
correspondence between in the classical
case the moment cumulant formulas has a
corresponding moment cumulant formula in
the free probability case and they were
able to develop the corresponding one
for this finite free case and there's
already been certain sorry did somebody
have a question there have already been
some noticeable applications one is to
what is called discrete Gaussian free
fields this is a result of a team goran
and also to what is called wine vine
garden calculus and this is a
observation of jonathan novak at UCSD
but combinatorially we don't have any
other sort of applications of any of
these types of things so thank you for
letting me speak today and thank your
attention
[Applause]
so just trying to understand something
the setting proofing price if you start
from any revolution graph you can always
add matching and keep it fun yes it is
it true way so you can also we're always
in if you have to revolution graph say
can I put one on top of that there
that's more complicated it should be
true well you have to do that you'd have
to do the free probability calculation
right I mean there's something special
about the two squares of D minus one
that comes out of this custom Michaela
and that's the fact that when you to
matching see cycle that might be a union
okay so actually I might have to go back
on what I originally said so it may be
so I'm not positive that if you started
with any Romney ocean graph that you
could add something that's Rama Newton
because somehow we would depend on the
distribution of the original graph but
no I take it back yeah I think you're
right yes I retake it you can find you
permutations if you wanted to pick a D
in and then he could build you a Rama
Newton graph of degree D on n vertices
that might be a multi graph bipartite
region finds a permutation yes and you
said something about T but how this goes
yeah yeah he sort of he keeps around he
he turns these one univariate
polynomials into multivariate
polynomials and
the the way he does it sort of keeps
more information about what's happening
so he's able to like look back at what
these new the coefficients of these new
variables are and use that to determine
which of the permutations was the one
that did it
other questions
[Applause]